Plus, 0% Interest
for 36 months.
Ends Monday.
>> LAWMAKERS MAKING PROGRESS ON
A ROUND OF STIMULUS, CHUCK
SCHUMER AND NANCY PELOSI
SIGNALING SUPPORT FOR A RELIEF
PACKAGE.
OUR NEXT GUEST TO THE COUNTRY
CAN’T AFFORD TO WAIT ANY
LONGER.
ANTHONY GONZALEZ, MEMBER OF THE
PROBLEM SOLVERS.
LET’S WALK THROUGH WHAT
AMERICANS MIGHT BE ABLE TO
EXPECT, WHAT RELIEF IS OUT
THERE FOR THEM SHOULD WE PASS
THIS RELIEF BILL.
>> THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO WERE HIT
THE HARDEST, THOSE WHO WERE
UNEMPLOYED AS A RESULT OF
SHUTDOWNS, THE BIGGEST REVENUE
LOSSES, STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT, SCHOOLS, IT IS
DESIGNED TO PLUG THE HOLE THAT
STILL EXISTS AS A RESULT OF
THIS.
>> HERE ARE THE SPECIFICS
INCLUDING $300 BILLION IN
FUNDING FOR SMALL BUSINESSES TO
PPP, $180 BILLION TO EXTEND
UNEMEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AT $300
PER WEEK FOR FOUR MONTHS AND A
TEMPORARY MORATORIUM ON
COVID-19 LIABILITY LAWSUITS.
I WANT TO NOT SPEND TOO MUCH
TIME LOOKING BACKWARD.
WHAT ARE THE PROSPECTS OF THIS
BILL BEING PASSED AND AT THE
SAME TIME WHAT HAS HELD UP THE
BILL?
>> YOU GUYS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
THE LAST ONE.
SPEAKER PELOSI DECIDED TO PLAY
POLITICS WITH THIS, A
$3 TRILLION BILL WE VOTED ON
TWO TIMES.
ANYTIME A BILL COMES TO VOTE
FOR YOU CAN PREDICT PRETTY
QUICKLY WHETHER IT WILL BECOME
LAW, THOSE WERE MESSAGING BILLS
AND ALL MEMBERS KNEW IT.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE REALLY STRUGGLING
AND SHE TIPPED OUR HAND WHEN
SHE HAD THE PRESS CONFERENCE.
THAT HELD US BACK IN MY
OPINION.
NOW WHAT IS HOLDING US BACK IS
OUR SENATE COLLEAGUES AND
SPEAKER.
THEY NEED TO CLOSE THE DEAL,
THE DEAL NEEDS TO GET DONE.
THEY ARE STILL IN DIFFERENT
PLACES.
WASHINGTON IS A LEADERSHIP
DRIVEN TALENT WE NEED THEM TO
COME FORWARD.
I’M MORE OPTIMISTIC TODAY THAN
I HAVE BEEN IN THE LAST 2 OR 3
MONTHS.
WHEN WE FIRST PUT IT OUT WE PUT
IT OUT IN SEPTEMBER.
WHEN WE PUT OUR OUR HOUSE
VERSION I WAS OPTIMISTIC AND
RBD PASSED AWAY, SLOWED THINGS
DOWN.
I’M OPTIMISTIC THEN BECAUSE YOU
HEAR THE RIGHT THINGS ABOUT
LEADERSHIP AND THEY ARE TALKING
WHICH DOESN’T USUALLY HAPPEN.
WE WILL SEE AND WE WILL KEEP
PUSHING.
>> IT IS A BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO
PUT THIS TOGETHER.
LESS THAN 30 SECONDS TO PUT A
FINE POINT ON THIS.
NANCY PELOSI HASN’T HAS TO BILL
UP TO THIS POINT BECAUSE DONALD
TRUMP IS PRESIDENT.
WE HEARD THERE IS NOW A NEW
PRESIDENT.
IS THAT IS WHY THINGS HAVE BEEN
HELD UP?
>> THAT IS THE BIGGEST REASON.
SENATE REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
ALL OVER THE MAP BUT I DO THINK
THAT IS COMING CLOSER TO
GATHER.
I TALKED TO SENATOR PORTMAN
FROM OHIO AND HE’S HAVING GOOD
DIALOGUE.
THEY ARE COMING CLOSER ON THE
SENATE SIDE BUT THE HOUSE SHE
SAID IT YESTERDAY, BASICALLY